let's talk about the gays we got some
good gay news a new study has found that
gay couples are more likely to be happy
and positive about their relationships
than straight couples childless men and
women are more satisfied with their
relationships and more likely to feel
valued by their partner straight parents
reported doing less to maintain their
relationship than any other group and
were the least likely to say I love you
talk about everything or pursued shared
interests same sex participants were
more positive about the quality of their
relationship and efforts to maintain it
so there's sort of two things going on
there that gay couples seem to be
happier but also that if you don't have
children you seem to be happier
regardless of whether it's a gay couple
or a straight couple there's a lot of
ways we could start here so now Rick I
believe you are straight you are the
straight member of the panel how is that
affected your happiness it's the child
this childless factor has bought me
decades of happy happy times that I
enjoy up to the cusp of 60 where I am as
of this August I have had a pretty
damned lucky happy child free life
doesn't mean I don't dig kids I do I
remember being one I wouldn't want to
have to hate my own past but I would say
that there's you know for all for all
the people that have kids that tell you
you're selfish because you didn't have a
kid go that added car-length you have on
the 405 going home you're welcome hahaha
yes I didn't stick another human in
front of you yeah the N is right the
carbon emissions there's all kinds of
ways there's a lot of reasons why that
added that added shelf full of things at
the store that you needed that someone
didn't grab ahead of you you're welcome
so you're doing this for the earth it's
about the earth yeah
yeah yeah I think nature makes people
that want to put the species ahead and
then nature designs millions of them
that go you guys go on ahead okay so
let's let's stick with that before we
get to the gay thing which is you're the
professional
panel in terms of gay relationships well
study I'm ecstatic yes I'm gay and
married yeah I must say that is I mean
you should be the happiest person on I'm
the happiest person alive you're on a
reality show right now about couples
you're a gay couple in therapy on the
show but I must say that as I was
actually reading this article my wife
came over my shoulder and was looking at
it and it's like literally I felt like a
steel door shut her womb closed like
like done she's like we're not having
kids ever you know and that's like you
know my list of things to do recently
and I feel like you know it's a
nerve-wracking thing to see all these
studies coming about how children
essentially make you miserable yeah um
but you know in terms of I think the the
headline of this study was fairly
misleading you write you know try to
address this yeah it kind of makes you
think like gays are ecstatic and
childless and and that's why but you
know in reality if you read through it
it says that new mothers and
heterosexual couples are happiest in
life I don't know what that exactly
means and how it differs from general
happiness but you know I think in terms
of in terms of gays putting in more
effort I think that honestly we're at a
point where now you know gay marriage
and and homosexual couples in general
kind of being more accepted and it's the
first time that we can be public about
our love and feel comfortable in some
cases so I feel like now it's the time
where we're proud of it we're putting in
the effort that I didn't really think
about that that as the rights have come
along that gays for the first time you
can be married and gay and it's not a
big deal so just that in itself but the
happiness level is just boosted and I
think it's it's become more apparent so
that's why it's it's more visible you
know yes we haven't been tainted by all
those years of legalized marriage where
we can you know be scornful of what it
is yeah so with everything you said
about about the kid thing what what
would you say to the people that say
you know all the rewards that you can
get from the children you know not just
driving them around to soccer but you
know seeing a kid grow up and send a kid
to college and all that sort of personal
pride do you feel that you you missed
any of that do you think there's some
level some people have a giant beer mug
that needs to be filled full of that
sensation I got the little shot glass
and sometimes giving a young comic some
advice is everything pump good we're
good that'll hold me yeah I've got camel
that'll last me a long time that's
interesting so the gays and the kids do
you think that once more gay people are
dying there's plenty obviously already
but does that is that ultimately going
to hamper this sort of what could be
temporary boost in happiness because I
mean I don't know I think you know the
thing is we and this isn't in any way a
knock on you know heterosexual couples
or the ability to conceive naturally or
anything like that it's just that you
know we can't accidentally get pregnant
it's not like we wake up one morning on
my baby gets one you know time to make
the donuts you know if you did it would
be really but you know it we have to
actually you know make a decision and
then take action and spend a lot of
money make a lot of decisions of how
we're going to do it and then and I
think that that kind of it's like to a
heterosexual couple we can't conceive
you know going to all this effort and
getting a child I think it kind of makes
the bond stronger makes the appreciation
stronger I mean I could be wrong in that
but I think I think that just the effort
that we have to put in you know might
make the appreciation more
unappreciative straight parents you well
there you have it if you're if you're
watching you're gay and you're watching
this and you're childless you're pretty
happy right about now
you